In Star Trek, Vector Dimensions takes you from one place to another, saving fuel (and the budget of special effects).
In the universe, it is a "safe way to travel."
Yes, sometimes, two people die horribly in rare circumstances ...
... but trillions of people move to work every morning without problems.
But, what if the dimension carrier is not as safe as ...
... What if the mortality rate does not indicate almost anything, but one hundred percent ...
Because the vector is a box for suicide.
First, how does the vector work?
There is technical evidence, with pages and pages of tedious details ...
That says very little.
Star Trek considered nothing if it was not constantly inconsistent, however, with the most common elements:
First, the dimension vector scans completely down to the smallest material, takes away the atoms and sends your pieces to the destination for reassembly.
But, is it you on the other end? Or a version that you think it?
okay, who are you ?
This is a big question, but let's try to be good scientists on this subject:
... We do not assume that there is a magic part within you that can not be measured.
After all, if it can not be measured, it means by definition that it can not affect anything.
Away from the hypotheses let's take you as they are: a set of atoms arranged in the thought that they are you.
Because the order of the atoms in the post-transport you is exactly the same as the pre-transport ...
You must be. The case was closed.
But ... maybe you still have this annoying feeling that your experience in the vector will be ...
... funny voice, bright light - then the eternal nothingness ..
... while on the planet, a new life, with all your memories until the moment before your death
... came into being I assumed it was you ...
How else?
Live life as short as task ...
... and a new creature with memories of you returning to the ship.
If true, multiply these by all life forms in all ships in all planets ...
... This technology is a silent holocaust ...
... which makes watching the episode of "Star Trek" a bleak watch.
And it's a simple mercy when a crew member takes a rapid elevator instead of a transmission
But again, the measurements are correct and maybe we are just confused, and we are already late to spend a holiday on a beautiful planet.
But regrouping is an optimistic version and can not be the way the vector really works ...
... because sometimes accidents combine two crew members into one - or split one into two.
There are not enough atoms you have to make you again, so it's a vector that converts atoms into energy and energy into atoms.
You are destroyed, used to charge the battery, then create it again.
This really sounds like death.
But the philosophers in the room are anxious </ i> to talk about the "Tessius" now - well.
Take this ship in an adventure. When some parts become damaged, you can replace them all until eventually there are no original parts.
When you return, is the "ship of Thessius" still the same ship "Thessius" in which sailed?
It seems so - this is what your body does daily by eating (bringing in new atoms) and taking out (loss of atoms).
Compare with "Katy Sark", a British ship that was burnt and restored with new parts.
Are you still the same as "Katy Sark"?
The result is the same: all new parts - only the time it took is different.
If you are happy with the philosophy of "Thessius Ship" through life (as you do previously), ...
If it happens to you as it happened to "Katy Sark" by the vector it should not matter. Yeah...?
But ... go into a conveyor belt with an assembly of idle atoms - and death will come to an end:
... before the transfer and after the transfer you can differ on who is you.
And when Scottie (you're pre-transport) says to you, "Sorry, there's an error in the atoms complex, give me a minute to fix it," you will not wait.
That the copy of you arrived at the destination is not a good thing.
The vector should be a suicidal box.
Well, why worry about the physics implications of the imaginative technology?
Because the vector of dimensions points us to the problem of consciousness.
We were quick to muddle the idea of ​​non-measurable before - because everything we can measure from a copy is identical ...
... but there is something completely different.
The dimension vector forces us to face the possibility that there is something about being a living creature that can not be measured from the outside
Do we not contain minds conscious of ourselves, how do we know that the rest of minds are conscious?
Truth be told, only you can really know that you are conscious ...
- It seems polite to give other people the benefit of doubt.
But it was a computer because he pretended to be conscious, how would you know?
You have a constant stream of awareness is your life.
You are the only one who can feel it, who can know if it exists and if it continues.
The dimension vector is scary because it causes a break in consciousness.
Make a copy that lives the life that you have left, without anyone knowing.
And with no one to know.
Although the vector dimensions are not real, but the breaks in consciousness are.
If you go for surgery, when you are under anesthesia, you can not be sure if you are the one who woke up.
For this matter, your bed may be a suicide machine.
Every night you go into a state of loss of consciousness, welcomes the reaper of souls ...
... Every morning, the first and only day of the life of the consciousness of a new creature.
It is impossible to know.
Sleep well tonight.
still here?
You can not stay awake forever.